el gobierno de venezuela hizo oficial la
suspensión de las negociaciones en
mexico con la oposición la causa el
empresario colombiano álex up que tras
16 meses retenido en cabo verde fue
extraditado a eeuu por presunto lavado
de dinero como expresión profunda de
nuestra protesta frente a la brutal
agresión
contra la persona y la investidura de
nuestro delegado de saab moral las
autoridades judiciales sospechan que
saab estuvo implicado en una trama que
le habría beneficiado de un programa de
subvención de alimentos y víveres su
abogado denuncia el reciente traslado
del bolsillo y se le ido este
procedimiento es ilegal y vergonzoso
para cabo verde y viola todas las reglas
del derecho internacional y las reglas
del derecho interno de cabo verde
interno lo que en agosto el gobierno y
la oposición retomaron los diálogos y
este 17 de octubre debía reanudarse en
una cuarta sesión entre reproches del
líder opositor juan guaidó condenó la
interrupción de los diálogos en un
contexto de periplo judicial que inició
en 2020 y sobre la onu pidió no aplicar
la extradición y garantizar los derechos
de saab